thank you for the introduction and thank
you for the invitation to speak here
it's right before lunch you guys have
all been sitting here so I decided to
keep my talk a little bit lighter than
some of the last two to two talks the
last slide will have a list of
references to paper so if you want to go
in and see all the actual equations in
theory that stuff's all all out there on
the web but what I wanted to talk about
first was actually well I wanted to
start with a video and so if I'm going
to start with the video it means have to
talk about some type of application so
the type of big data that I work with
our data that come from physical
simulations so we often display these as
pictures but what this is is this is a
physics soon soon ulation of a cylinder
with some type of complex internal
geometry and what we're doing is we're
heating this from one side and we're
seeing what parts of the cylinder get
hot so there there are different types
of materials in this simulator sorry in
the sill cylinder we want to make sure
that the important bits inside don't get
to get to too hot so this is an abstract
representation of all sorts of
complicated geometries that might show
up in different types of applications
but what's interesting about these these
data is all the simulation data sort of
happens inside this cylinder here and we
have points at time space and usually
different types of features I at at at
each point too so I'll describe or I'll
focus a little bit more on one
particular study we did and so we're
going to go through a couple of
applications why we need tall tall tall
and skinny QRS and then we'll show you
how we actually do them so the
particular study we did most recently
was we had a big brick and this brick
was composed of two different materials
so there was something that sort of
looked like steel and there was
something that sort of looked like foam
so if you look at this brick here you
can see that there that there are these
bubbles inside of it so those bubbles
are foam bubbles and what we want to do
is understand
and how he propagates in this brick if
we heat one end so if we apply heat on
one end and then we look at the
temperature on the other end so now just
taking one of these bricks with a set of
positions of these foam bubbles and
running it through a nonlinear heat
Trant transfer code at Sandia National
Labs takes about five hours on eight
processors so this is using one of their
big big thermal codes that's probably as
fast as these these things can go what
we did was we ran this code 8192 times
where we varied the position of the
bubbles and the size of the bubbles so
in particular we looked at 64 different
bubble sizes and we looked at a hundred
and twenty eight different positions of
every bubble so if you multiply those
two out you get 8109 and 92 if you look
at how many cpu hours we spent doing
this that's around 400,000 cpu hours so
this actually output about four and a
half terabytes of data that stored his
netcdf files and what we wanted to do is
do some type of glow global analysis or
what's called in the literature model
order reduction on this saw data to
build an approximation for what this
model does so that we can do not 8,000
runs of this but around a hundred
thousand runs without burning about a
hundred times as many CPU hours that'd
be about 40 million CPU hours I think if
I did that right in my head alright so
we've got this four and a half terabytes
of data which actually if anyone else
wants to play with this or this would be
a useful test set for other people it's
out there on the web so this is at the
open science data cloud hosted at the
University of Chicago so if if anyone
would like large spatiotemporal
distributed data sets and lots of them
they're all there so what are we really
trying to I do what we're trying to
figure out what the temperature looks
like at that end plate there so we can
get from one side we look at the other
case and we're looking at how much of
that final surface is sort of too hot so
as we vary this bubble size there
a regime where it looks like an
insulator so there's not much hot and
then there's a resume where it doesn't
look like an insulator and what we want
to do is predict this threshold based on
all of this this data so how do we do it
well we actually end up constructing a
nice cool little matrix equation so we
actually treat each simulation as a
column of some big data matrix a
actually it turns out we treat a hundred
and twenty eight of these soon ulations
as a column of this matrix a so we
concatenate all of the different bubble
locations take two together into one big
matrix so we end up with a five billion
by 64 matrix out of stitching all of
these simulations to gather so this is
about 2.2 terabytes of data if you just
look at the double Precision's you
actually store in a real system there's
a little bit more overhead but let's
just say it's 2.2 tear tear row bytes
then we construct an SVD of this so we
get enormous matrix u we get Sigma and V
Trent transpose so what we're going to
talk about after we discuss the
application is how you do this SVD on
map map reducing a couple different
choices for how you might do it
depending on your application once we
have the SVD we actually just get out
the components of you corresponding to
that face so when we put this sim
simulation in every point in this brick
becomes a row in our matrix a and so we
can just extract a small subset of those
and do a whole bunch of analysis on that
subset in order to figure out how this
phase phase phase Tran transition
happens so once we have that we can do
it on the laptop and that's what my
colleague did after we extracted that
subset and so what do you see alright so
the blue line is the true face phase
transition between these two regimes the
red circles are what we get from our
method and the green dots which don't
show up all that well but I apologize
about that that's what you get if you
don't do the SVD step so you might say
well
bother with all this big expensive SVD
things why not just go in and get the
data from that soon simulation at those
points and do some type of analysis just
on this final surface you're interested
in so ignore the fact that there's the
rest of the soona soona mutilations
after this is really cheap and expense
there's no no SPD in fault well the
reason you don't want to do do is you
get the wrong answer so you get it more
or less right so there's a laser pointer
on this thing somewhere so you get it
more or less right that is if you look
at this plot it kind of looks the same
the green dots but then again these are
actually quite a bit different so you
sort of get it in the wrong position and
rsvd tech tech technique gets it much
better so so the other thing you can do
with this SVD tech technique is actually
predict what new simulations look like
so suppose you actually want to do those
a hundred thousand studies on on on this
using that same idea you can compute
some type of interpolation of the
singular values and vectors themselves
i'm not going to go into detail just
because that's a different talk but what
happens here is you can compute a
simulation about a hundred times faster
via this model we construct on the SVD
now it's an approximation but it comes
with an error estimate so here's the
true error and here's our error estimate
for a representative piece of this brick
and so what you can see is where this
thing is high you do tend to see high
error so this is sort of the temperature
offset and degrees Celsius I believe
more over you can see that over sort of
also so s here are the sizes of bubbles
so as we vary the size of bubbles you
can see sort of how our error looks and
so we get about two digits of accuracy
in this as we vary vary this and it goes
about a hundred times time time's up
faster so the idea here is you can do
this big expensive big data analysis and
then construct a model that you can
evaluate a hundred times faster so we've
seen a lot of these these ideas Sergei
mentioned corsets yesterday
this is what's called reduced-order
modeling in sin suen simulation
literature but you can do do all these
things a lot faster and so that's why we
want to compute this big SVD so let's
see how am i doing on time do I have
time for this video I think so so
another so so I should say that the
current the current stuff is small what
we want to be able to do is to scale up
to data that looks like this so this is
a large eddy soon simulation so I
believe it's about 100 time steps where
every time step is about four and a half
million points so here we're doing an
SVD for a different reason but we
actually want to do multiple simulations
that look look like this at the moment
we're just taking this for 45 million is
it it's actually so so 45 million data
points a thousand time sets but each
data point has four different features
associated with associated with it so
it's really 160 million so here they
just did a single SVD of this data set
in order to figure out these bubbles
that come come back up so this is a
simulation of a jet engine and what they
want to do is figure out a way of making
this jet engine qui quieter on military
installations it turns out that the
hearing protection we can apply isn't
sufficient to enable people to work for
for for more than a couple minutes on an
aircraft carrier deck if they can make a
jet engine qui quieter you can get
people out there there longer so what
what what what they did did here was a
single SVD of this 160 million by a
thousand matrix to find those bubbles
that came came came back up this helped
them understand where the acoustic
energy was going and taught him a couple
things that they didn't know about how
the acoustic waves were propagating in
this particular jet so I should also say
that this was done by a guy who usually
runs simulations on one and a half
million cores out at Lawrence Livermore
National Labs and he was very excited to
use our map map
reduce implementation of SB d just
because he didn't have to deal with the
complexities of manipulating data and
MPI this is not a particularly fun thing
to do if you've ever had to work with
that that an MPI okay but now we've been
talking about big data so i have a
question is this big big data so i said
four-and-a-half tear terabytes Sergey
yesterday said that big data has two
properties so it's too big for one hard
drive so we can check off that one the
other thing he said was that there's a
skewed distribution now I don't know
what the skewed distribution in here so
i'm not sure we qualify as big data
under that one but here I think Sergey
didn't tell us that he was really
talking about an acronym so he was
talking about but big data so this is
big internet giant data so Google Yahoo
everyone else what are we looking at
we're looking at big data or big
engineering data all right so a little
bit different we don't have quite quite
quite out of skew but it's still there
very large all right all the matrices
we've seen are fairly tall and skinny I
said five billion by 64 I said 45
million by a thousand what's an
operational definition of tall and
skinny well so Austin has my favorite
which is that you can treat order
n-squared as a constant effectively so
order N squared is so small compared to
a more your total data size that you can
basically ignore any communication of
order N squared square to work so Jim
will give us a talk on Thursday and he'd
probably probably say something about
moving data from fast memory to sorry
from slow memory too fast memory and how
big the sizes are in things things I
like this I just think of this is really
what you should think so all of these
problems n was approximately at most a
thousand so a thousand times so a
thousand times a thousand a million
eight bytes per entry there's about
eight megabytes I think the cash on my
phone is now bigger than eight megabytes
or something like that so these are
small problems
you can compute and transfer them
extremely efficiently so the key routine
we're going to use to do all of these
big sv there's actually a QR routine so
the title of talk was doing QR and so
this is why the title of talk is really
QR and not SVD so what is a QR and why
does it help us get an SVD well the QR
of an m-by-n matrix is a decomposition
into an orthogonal matrix times an upper
triangular matrix so q is orthogonal r
is nice and small so it's n by n and qs
m by n so r is this nice tiny n by n
thing we can move around efficiently q
is big nasty and bad so suppose we
actually had a QR how does that help us
get an SPD well this is an old idea
called rsvd what you do is you first do
a QR of your matrix a so you get Q&R and
then you do an SPD of your matrix are so
that that'll give you a sigma v and it
turns out that if you just take the
product of you from this matrix r and
multiply it against the matrix q you
actually get out the SVD so the SVD is
is unique up to some sign of properties
and this will get you one of those SVD
so this is what we're going to do when
we compute these big SPD's all right
Michael was telling us about a random
sampling procedure other people were
telling us about about MPI
implementations there are good and MPI
implementations about this as a library
called scale a pack that's been
optimized to death over the last few
years what's left to do well if your
data is not in an MPI cluster or your
data is somewhere else or you don't even
want to work with your data an MPI
cluster just because it's I you don't
have enough space on the parallel file
system or something like that you can't
always use MPI for some of these big
data things or it just might be too
costly to get your data into the MPI
cluster in the first place so what we're
going to do is we're going to look at
using a map map reduce implementation of
this so how do we store tall and skinny
matrices and Map Reduce we're going to
do the obvious thing here we're going to
take our tall and skinny matrix a and
let Hadoop divide it up into blocks so
we're going to store either a single row
as each record of this and so I should
say that these are all dense problems
there's no sparsity to take advantage of
here so we're basically go go going to
store our matrix as a collection of
Records where every record is a row what
Hadoop does or what a MapReduce system
does is it breaks it up into all sorts
of different blocks so effectively what
we're doing is we're taking our matrix
and computing some type of row partition
of it so this is all done by by of the
system although we might actually store
be by n blocks where B is something not
too big it may be up to uh n so then
every matrix AI is going to be an input
to what to to to a map task I'm not
telling you guys about MapReduce just
because I wanted to go over some videos
instead and we've seen a lot about
MapReduce already so if you're not
familiar with it please come up and chat
with me afterwards just a couple of
backup slides all right so still isn't
this relatively easy to do what's the
big deal we want to compute a is equal
to q q QR we know if we form the normal
equations a transpose a that's a nice
small matrix everything involved there
is n by n I said that that's free or
cheap once we have that we can compute
Achille esky factorization of a
transpose a that actually gives us the r
and q are and then we can compute q by a
r inverse so has this work in map map I
reduce we take you chose next trend
index there we take our little matrix a
one we just compute a transpose a that's
something we can do locally and that's
that's not necessarily N squared work
but it's fairly efficient every map or
outputs it's a little local n by n block
I said that that was cheap the reducer
just sums all these things up and
compute satchel esky factorization of
them and then we just map the matrix a I
back to a ir r inverse so this is great
if your problem is well conditioned so
if a is a well conditioned matrix this
is a fantastic algorithm but if a is ill
conditioned and even modestly so then
your are
matrix is not going to have much
accuracy left and a bigger problem is a
lot of applications actually need Q to
be numerically orthogonal so if you do
this Q is not going to be numerically
orthogonal so what what actually happens
so here we're varying the condition
number of our matrix as a sort of how
sensitive that matrix is too small small
changes here we're looking at the
numerical orthogonality of Q this matrix
here is 10,000 x 10 these problems just
get worse if your matrix is bigger so if
your condition number is is 10 to the
eighth that's not all that large for
some some some types of applications
then you basically lost all orthogonal t
and Q so Q is very far from an
orthogonal matrix so if you actually
need an orthogonal Q this procedure
isn't going and going to work so we're
going to talk about four things that are
better in the nine minutes I have left
so that's about two minutes each it's a
good thing that three of them are
basically riffs on the same idea so we
can go through those pretty quickly so
these are all based on a communication
avoiding QR algorithm that Jim Demel
proposed and they all give us much
better stability results so the first
thing is is essentially a riff on the
same idea of using a are inverse so here
we there's an incredibly simple
procedure to get the rfactor numerically
accurate so if you get are numerically
accurate that is you avoid the normal
equations then you can get not
necessarily good results but results
that are orthogonal out much further
than the a the a transpose a algorithm
so this these two algorithms cost
exactly the same amount up to small
numbers now if you actually want
orthogonal things we're going to discuss
three algorithms number three here is
actually kind of cool and incorporate
some ideas from the randomized matrix
literature on sampling so this and this
actually costs about the same amount to
so if you want nearly full orthogonal T
you can get it at not too much extra
work we can't necessarily prove that
one works unfortunately so it's kind of
a heuristic but it's a heuristic that
would work for a lot of applications so
just to be a little bit more precise
here what happens if we just want to
read a matrix a so this takes about two
hundred and fifty-three seconds in our
map map Bob reduce system if the matrix
is about 200 gigabytes if we want to
write out the matrix a it takes about a
thousand seconds if we want to just just
compute are using our new algorithm it
takes about five hundred seconds so it's
about twice as long if we want to go in
and get q is equal to ei R inverse
that's with nothing fancy that's using
the old algorithm so that old blue line
that wasn't precise takes about 1,600
seconds and if you want to get a
provably numerically orthogonal a it
takes about three thousand seconds these
codes are all available so Austin's done
a great job who's back in the audience
there has done a great job of actually
writing these things up and documenting
them and making them useful for for for
other people so feel free to use them
what's the big idea so the big idea here
is if you do a QR iteration it's a real
reduce operation so if I want to compute
a QR iterate or a QR factorization of
the matrix a and i had my matrix a in
four blocks then what i can do is i can
do local q hours of every block so i
take a one i do a QR that gives me q 1
and r 1 if i do a two i get q 2 and r 2
q 3 and r 3 so i can do one iteration of
this and get something that is not quite
a QR factorization yet but this batrix a
was originally a 10 by n now it's down
to 4 n by n so I've reduced its size by
a factor of roughly 2 in this case and
this is a bad isn't necessarily the best
or the the best case for others but I
can just recurse on this for n by n
matrix so if I compute a QR
factorization of that then the product
of this Q and this Q again this can be
done locally very easily because this
has a block diagonal structure is the QR
factor is a
the matrix so you can stitch these QR
factorizations together and actually
compose them to get a QR factorization
of the entire matrix so this is why this
algorithm is a great fit for map napa
reduce you can also show that
adaptations of the same idea give you
ways of minimizing communication for any
type of QR algorithm you want to do so
that's what Jim Jim Demel did in their
2008 paper so how would this work if you
were to do do this not or how would this
work if you were to do do all this just
on one machine well what you can also do
is just read in say the first block of
the matrix a computer q q QR of that
that gives you are read in the second
block in the matrix a compute a QR of
that that gives you another are and just
keep reading in blocks and updating your
q QR so you get some really complicated
Q here but you can do do all these
things really efficiently what we do in
map map reduce is just combine these two
two two two ideas so within each mapper
we're reading blocks in the matrix a and
computing QR factorization so we can do
do all this and roughly I think we
usually read four times n rows of the
matrix a and then compute a QR
factorization so that's roughly time n
squared so each of these things is
basically constant time operation as n
squared is free way of looking at the
world and the same thing for updating
all of these between mappers we just
compute a QR within each mapper and then
the reducer we send all of our small
matrices are back to one computer and
have them compute and have that that
computer computer single QR
factorization so we're just taking that
reduction tree and looking at it on map
map reduce now I said it so so one
problem with that algorithm is you
actually have to send everything down to
one reducer in the end so if you had a
really large input matrix there's some
properties of Hadoop that make it
painful to actually
can communicate data around so
occasionally you have to add an
additional MapReduce iteration for
efficiency so this is a detail some of
the implementation so if you have
questions about this let me know
afterwards but there are some
complexities with doing doing this I'm
very very tall and skinny matrices this
gets you are how do you get Q so again
that was this algorithm one here how do
you get Q well you do a are so so
algorithms to an algorithm three are
just doing a r inverse with an
additional step of iterative refinement
so I I'm not going to describe how to
get a r inverse you just basically take
our it's n by n it's tiny you just
distribute it to all processors and then
just compute a r inverse with one
additional map map but reduce iteration
how do you do a turret of refinement you
just repeat this entire procedure again
so in iterative refinement you compute q
q is not numerically orthogonal but then
you compute a QR factorization of that q
because it's not numerically orthogonal
you get a non-trivial are and you just
repeat this entire thing so it's kind of
like taking a Newton step if you're
familiar with some of these other ideas
so you just repeat the entire thing
again it's it's it's a folklore theorem
that two iterations of this are enough
every time I give this talk someone
suggests that it's attributable to a
different person but there is a lot of
evidence that suggests that two
iterations of this are enough to get a
numerically orthogonal q the problem is
you might not want to do this entire
procedure twice so what could you do
instead so here's where the randomized
guys come in and save our butts I guess
in this case if you just grab a random
sample of your mate of your rows and
this might be actually difficult to
construct in Hadoop so there's some
questions about how to do this or why we
can't really do do why we can't actually
do do all this and Hadoop come up and
talk talk to me afterwards but you can
approximate this and had you pretty
efficiently so you grab a random sample
of your matrix a and then you compute a
QR of that matrix and
via from blendin pick and what Michael
talked about was that you can use these
to precondition your problem so what
we're doing here is we're using that
random sample arose to precondition the
ill conditioning on our problem and then
if you just do one step of tsq are you
weak you can sort of view this as pseudo
iterative refinement you're not doing a
full QR up front but you're doing a full
QR at the next step and this this is
good enough to get you actually
numerically orthogonal results all the
way along here and actually beats
exactly iterative refinement although
there's some some deep details here the
problem is we can't prove that you get
numerically or thought mental results
here for some applications it's nice to
be able to prove that upfront in which
case we really do have to go through a
somewhat expensive procedure of storing
a lot of intermediate output data queue
tracing where it comes from and feeding
the data back to this so there's a way
of doing this in map map ba reduce
basically you just have to tag some of
your outputs which is which actually
took us a while to get right because it
was it's not the most natural thing to
do in map map reduce so we have all
sorts of numbers on this I'm out of time
we have a performance model that shows
you how well you do versus how well you
might be able to do in theory and we do
pretty well so for matrices with a cut
with lots of rows it takes a while to do
our exact algorithm but we have all
sorts of approximations in case you
don't don't need need of that so papers
here we've got some oh it turns out I've
got some other alternative acronyms for
big here so in case you don't you want
of other interpretations of big it could
be bloody imposing graphs building
impressions of ground truth block-wise
independent guesses or my personal
favorite is this one
so best implemented at Google anyway
with that their other questions and
references here so thank you let's pick
one